all right Brandon is with us in New York
hey Brandon welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show hey Dave thanks thanks for having
me
sure what's up so got a family business
question
I love listen here does all your answers
on on this stuff so we are five
generation dairy farm upstate New York
and six years ago we decided to start
our own farm processing business to kind
of capitalize on on our you know
heritage I guess but so each year we've
doubled our business my wife and I run
the processing distribution my mother
and father-in-law run the dairy
operation and so each year we've doubled
sales so obviously cash flow has always
been a an issue because we keep
reinvesting to keep growing the business
so getting to our sixth year in business
with the processing time getting to the
point where you know we do this
full-time but I haven't been able to
save for retirement like we should for
my wife and I I'm 30 she's 25 we have
four kids all under the age of six and
so I need to kind of I don't know if I
should refocus and start having the
business chaos we make a very small
salary so that we can invest into our
personal retirement or do you because
we've been blessed with opportunities do
you keep investing in our small business
on the processing side because it is
investing in ourselves and our family so
you own you own the processing and your
mother-in-law and father-in-law own the
dairy farm so we're all together on it
it's a four-way partnership know why 550
they have 50% so how does it work when
you invest the money from the processing
that you're running back into the
processing and you don't take any money
home
and they didn't put any money in and
they own the rest of it well it's kind
of just been a mutual deal where it's
all of our business they focus on the
producing of the milk yes so what do you
what is your personal income my wife and
I we bring in like thirty four I think
we did last year we brought in granted
you notice that what is the per what is
the processing plant producing top-line
gross revenues right now here today
I looked we're at 1.2 million and you're
being paid thirty thousand dollars to
run that yeah that's asinine are well
and that's that's kind of been our
dilemma is we keep investing in the
business because we want it to grow and
be there no that's asinine but listen
there's two problems okay are three
problems yeah
one is families involved two is it's a
small business three is it's a farm all
three of these things are highly
emotional mm-hmm
and farmers we all those of us that are
not farmers those of us that love
farmers we get it but sometimes you guys
become completely illogical in your love
of the farm and family business does the
same thing and small business does the
same thing and you got you got like a
threesome going here killing you okay so
you guys got to back up and start
running this like a multi-million dollar
company which it is mm-hmm and people
that are major executives and
multi-million dollar companies do not
make thirty thousand dollars a year
right I don't care if you're an
electrician with 14 trucks I don't care
if you're heating air guy I don't care
if you're a small home builder I don't
care if you make milk in upstate New
York doesn't matter to me it's a
multi-million dollar business and the
guy running it needs to take home more
than 30 grand he's got four small
children and he needs to be investing
for his future and for their college and
taking care of his family right right
and after you take home a living wage
which are not yet then what is left can
be used to invest into the business
okay so even even though the business is
growing and taking home a hefty salary
which kind of inhibit our biggest things
it doesn't and hit whatever they're
growing fine a hefty salary would be
fifty to a hundred thousand dollars a
year would be a reasonable income for
you in this situation thirty is asinine
if you wanted to take a job working for
somebody else and you were gonna run an
organization that size and they wanted
to pay you 30 you would laugh at them
and rightly so do that for yourself and
for your family business as well